Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Et voilà, on y est. Septante Minutes Avec reprend enfin pour une saison deux.
Je sais que je vous ai fait attendre et que cette pause aura été plus longue que prévu. Toutes mes excuses pour ça.
On démarre cette nouvelle saison avec un sujet assez sensible puisqu'il s'agit des maladies mentales.
Je me suis rendu à Uccle, dans l'hôpital psychiatrique de Fond'Roy, pour rencontrer le docteur Vincent Dubois, qui a accepté de me rencontrer pour parler de schizophrénie.
C'est un sujet qui est souvent mal compris, mal connu du grand public. On a pu discuter de la nature de la maladie
et des conséquences qu'elle peut avoir sur la vie de la personne, mais aussi du traitement, de l'approche médicale et évidemment de la fameuse question du paternalisme, puisque souvent
les patients arrivent contre leur gré.
C'est un échange dont je suis très content. Le docteur Vincent Dubois a fait preuve d'une grande pédagogie et je l'en remercie.
Mais voilà, il y a une mauvaise nouvelle.
Juste après l'enregistrement de l'épisode bonus, je me suis rendu à l'École 19 pour préparer ma première chronique pour La Libre Belgique et j'ai utilisé mon magnifique enregistreur pour garder une trace de l'entretien avec le staff.
Le problème, c'est que j'ai oublié de régler mon matériel avant l'interview du docteur Dubois. Du coup, c'est les micros internes qui ont été utilisés et pas les vrais bons micros que j'utilise normalement.
Je vous cache pas que, voilà, la prise de son de cet épisode laisse carrément à désirer. C'est loin d'être horrible, c'est tout à fait supportable, mais voilà, ça s'entend.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que ça ne se reproduira plus pour les prochains épisodes dont je vous parlerai en fin d'émission.
C'est parti. Nous sommes aujourd'hui avec Vincent Dubois. Vincent Dubois, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter pour nos auditeurs qui ne vous connaissent peut-être pas ?
Eh bien voilà, je suis psychiatre de formation. Et puis j'ai longtemps aussi travaillé dans un milieu hospitalier, mais un milieu académique aussi.
Donc, après mes études et après ma formation comme psychiatre, j'ai entamé une thèse de doctorat dans un domaine
qui était à l'époque assez nouveau, à savoir les interventions dans le champ de la santé mentale qu'on faisait dans des pays en développement qui connaissaient des violences de masse.
Donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé au Cambodge, notamment. J'ai fait une thèse de doctorat sur ce qu'on pouvait imaginer et faire pour diminuer la souffrance des gens qui vivaient cela.
Et puis je suis resté pendant de nombreuses années à Saint-Luc, à l'hôpital clinique universitaire Saint-Luc, où j'animais un service de psychiatrie, mais aussi j'enseignais à la faculté de médecine, ce que je fais toujours aujourd'hui.
Mais depuis 2013, j'ai repris la direction médicale d'un groupe hospitalier qui s'appelle Epsylon, qui gère et anime trois cliniques psychiatriques, donc uniquement psychiatriques,
à savoir la clinique Laramée, la clinique Fond'Roy et la clinique Area+, qui, elle, se concentre uniquement sur les adolescents.
Alors, on va se concentrer aujourd'hui, même si le champ déjà de la santé mentale, mais plus précisément des maladies mentales, ces champs-là sont très larges.
On va se concentrer aujourd'hui sur la question de la schizophrénie, qui est déjà une vaste question. Première question pour commencer.
Déjà, question à la fois très simple et très complexe. Je pense que la définition de la schizophrénie n'est pas forcément bien connue du grand public.
Elle est même souvent méconnue. Il y a beaucoup de désinformation. On a une mauvaise idée de ce que ça signifie. Comment est-ce que vous expliqueriez à un néophyte ce que c'est finalement la schizophrénie ?
La schizophrénie, on peut quand même la décrire avant tout comme une maladie, une maladie mentale. Quand on dit maladie, ben ça veut dire que c'est un ensemble de symptômes, c'est un syndrome.
Quand on dit un syndrome, c'est un ensemble de symptômes qui recouvrent tant des champs psychologiques que des champs organiques, biologiques.
Donc la schizophrénie, par rapport à d'autres pathologies de santé mentale, est certainement une maladie dans laquelle les symptômes les plus prédominants peuvent apparaître en tout cas comme d'ordre psychologique.
À savoir, on a des hallucinations, on a des troubles de la pensée, on a des délires. Hein, le délire, c'est un trouble de la pensée.
Il peut avoir plusieurs formes, hein, c'est des délires d'interprétation. On se sent espionné, on se sent observé.
On a toutes sortes d'idées tout à fait bizarres, en tout cas sur le monde. Mais en même temps, on sait aujourd'hui que la schizophrénie a une part importante de dimension biologique.
Et on voit ces jeunes, parce que souvent ça arrive très jeune malheureusement, perdre des facultés importantes, ont des troubles cognitifs, comme on dit.
Donc vraiment, les facultés cognitives sont atteintes. On voit aussi des ralentissements psychomoteurs. Donc c'est une maladie—
c'est une des maladies les plus graves en psychiatrie, à savoir qu'elle débute souvent très jeune et elle va durer toute la vie.
Elle est souvent en effet mal comprise, mal acceptée. Elle est tout aussi handicapante qu'un grave handicap physique ou mental.
Mais néanmoins, dans le grand public, on a en effet, comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure, des impressions souvent très—
Mh.
...très, très ambivalentes par rapport à ces pathologies.
Pour avoir une meilleure idée de peut-être l'impact de cette maladie, le pourcentage de gens impactés par cette maladie, on parle de...
On parle de un pour cent de la population.
Un pour cent.
Donc c'est quand même, voilà, c'est une vraie maladie dont on connaît bien la prévalence et l'incidence au niveau de la santé publique.
Une maladie qui a toujours existé, contrairement à la santé mentale, j'imagine qu'on en parlera, dont le champ n'a fait que s'étendre à travers l'histoire.
La schizophrénie est décrite depuis la nuit des temps. On connaît des descriptions dans la littérature, dans les premiers traités médicaux.
La schizophrénie est une maladie qui a toujours existé, dont la fréquence ne change, pour finir, pas tellement à travers les siècles.
Ce qui d'ailleurs nous fait dire que le versant biologique, la transmission biologique est sans doute assez forte.
Plus que le facteur environnemental alors ?
Exactement, exactement. Mais néanmoins, mais néanmoins, donc la schizophrénie demeure assez constante à travers les siècles.
Par contre, la manière dont elle va s'exprimer, la manière dont on va s'en occuper, tout ça, elle, par contre, va changer énormément à travers les âges.
Mais donc pour approfondir cette question-là, la question de la cause, la question de la source de la schizophrénie, est-ce qu'on a une réponse aujourd'hui ?
À savoir si elle est génétique, savoir s'il y a un facteur héréditaire ?
Voilà. Alors, on est en effet plus loin que par le passé, mais on n'est pas encore au bout. Ça reste en grande partie assez mystérieux.
On a des idées, on parle aujourd'hui de vulnérabilité, de vulnérabilité génétique, de vulnérabilité biologique. On n'est pas dans des facteurs, je dirais, de cause à effet direct comme on pourrait espérer dans une meilleure compréhension.
Donc ça reste un ensemble de facteurs de fragilité qui, dans un contexte particulier, vont s'exprimer. La vulnérabilité génétique aujourd'hui est mieux connue qu'avant, même si elle est beaucoup plus complexe qu'on l'imaginait.
Elle touche à un ensemble de gènes. Ce n'est pas qu'un seul gène. Comme je vous dis, elle est plutôt en ordre de fragilité que dans une cause directe.
Elle exprime souvent une fragilité, mais qu'on retrouve dans des familles, qui touchent aussi d'autres maladies.
Donc on parle là de spectre, hein, d'un spectre génétique, de fragilité génétique. Et puis bien sûr, on sait aussi qu'il y a vraisemblablement des hypothèses par rapport à une fragilité biologique.
On a parlé même d'origine virale de la schizophrénie. Donc on a quelques éléments comme ça qui assurent aujourd'hui que le versant en tout cas biologique de la schizophrénie est aujourd'hui indiscutable.
Mais donc on sent bien que ça reste encore très flou d'après ce que vous dites.
C'est flou et certainement pas— ce n'est pas dans une causalité directe. C'est, je crois, un message. Ça peut être frustrant pour ceux qui aimeraient vraiment, je dirais, comprendre les choses jusqu'au bout.
Ça laisse aussi une part de liberté importante,
par rapport au patient, par rapport à la famille, en disant que voilà,
même si cette fragilité existe, il y a encore pas mal de choses très importantes dans l'environnement qui peuvent profondément modifier une maladie qui viendrait à s'exprimer.
Des choses comme ?
Le stress, la qualité des relations dans la famille, la manière dont on va traiter les choses au plus tôt, hein. On sait aujourd'hui que la schizophrénie,
ça se traite au plus tôt, au mieux, hein, puisque très vite, les stigmates de la maladie, les stigmates sociaux,
le stigma social, le fait de perdre des habilités sociales, de perdre un environnement va certainement empirer l'évolution de la maladie.
Donc c'est toutes des choses pour lesquelles on est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus précis. Il y a des pays d'ailleurs qui vont assez loin là-dedans puisqu'ils font de la détection très très précoce, déjà dès les primaires.
C'est des choses aujourd'hui qui sont parfois discutables, hein, mais qui existent dans certains pays.
Mais donc on peut être alors porteur de cette vulnérabilité sans forcément en être conscient. Est-ce qu'on peut
être porteur d'une maladie, voilà, d'une schizophrénie, je ne sais pas quel terme employer, mais qui est déclenchée, qui est avérée
sans en être conscient, sans consulter des services médicaux et voilà, vivre sa vie schizophrène à l'extérieur de l'hôpital ?
Alors c'est très difficile de répondre à ça. C'est une vraie question, hein, parce qu'on s'est toujours dit qu'il y a certainement des gens, vous savez, la variété des vies et des personnalités et des teintes,
je dirais, qu'on retrouve dans la population est certainement beaucoup plus vaste que ce que les médecins connaissent, puisque a priori, nous ne rencontrons que des gens
qui, un, se sentent malades ou qui sont amenés par d'autres qui les trouvent malades.
Mais à côté de ça, vous avez encore une quantité de gens qui, sans doute, ont des vies particulières, des vies peut-être un peu plus spéciales, bon, qui ne sont pas forcément dans la norme et qui traversent cela sans trop de difficultés.
Mais néanmoins, puisqu'on parle de schizophrénie, c'est vrai que dans la majorité des cas, les problèmes arrivent soit de manière très brutale, hein.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le fameux coup de tonnerre dans un ciel serein. C'est un jeune à la fin de son adolescence qui, en très peu de temps, va développer des symptômes parfois très aigus.
Mais vous avez aussi des situations un peu plus complexes où on voit des jeunes qui déjà dès la fin des primaires, le début des humanités,
ont des stigmates, hein, sont des jeunes qu'on retrouve au fond de la classe, qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'amis, qui ont parfois des comportements un peu étranges, un peu bizarres.
C'est des jeunes dont on va se moquer. Et petit à petit, eh bien se présenteront différents symptômes qui à ce moment-là,
rentrent dans un syndrome schizophrénique beaucoup plus lent, beaucoup plus latent et qui est en général de pronostic un peu plus difficile.
Je remarque que vous parlez de jeunes adultes. Est-ce que c'est à ce moment-là que la schizophrénie se présente ?
Absolument. Donc la schizophrénie, par définition, est une maladie globalement de la fin de l'adolescence, enfin parfois même en pleine adolescence.
Grosso modo, on parle d'un début entre quinze et vingt-cinq ans.
D'accord, OK. Et une fois que le patient, voilà, vient soit spontanément, soit en quelque sorte forcé de rentrer dans l'hôpital psychiatrique, comment est-ce que la schizophrénie est traitée à ce moment-là ?
Donc c'est déjà— enfin, peut-être, voilà, je me permets d'insister sur ce que vous venez de dire, à savoir que c'est déjà une étape très importante, la manière dont il va venir aux soins.
Puisque paradoxalement, je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que c'était une des maladies les plus graves en psychiatrie, paradoxalement,
c'est certainement les patients qui ont le plus de mal à, un, reconnaître qu'ils sont malades, donc avoir la conscience de cela,
et de deux, demander de l'aide.
Donc très souvent, on rencontre malheureusement des situations qui évoluent déjà depuis un certain nombre de temps parce que le jeune ne veut pas consulter et en général, il vient à la consultation poussé dans le dos—
Par son entourage, c'est encore un cas de figure assez favorable,
mais parfois bien pire.
C'est-à-dire que là, il y a eu déjà un événement, il y a déjà eu un trouble
du comportement sur l'ordre public, il y a eu une intervention de la police, il y a eu une intervention, je dirais,
du procureur à travers cette fameuse loi, on en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure, mais qui clairement concerne cette population cible, à savoir la loi de mise en observation qui nous permet
d'offrir, enfin de proposer des soins, d'imposer même des soins à des patients qui ne se sentent ni malades,
qui ne désirent pas se soigner, mais qui présentent un danger pour eux-mêmes d'abord, c'est souvent ça l'histoire, l'esprit de la loi, mais parfois aussi pour les autres.
Et donc on rencontre ces jeunes dans une situation plus ou moins favorable dès le départ.
Et je dirais que la première chose à faire est quand même souvent de devoir, je dirais, manager, gérer les symptômes qui sont parfois extrêmement bruyants, comme on dit.
C'est pas parce qu'ils crient forcément, même si ça arrive, mais c'est parce que le délire est particulièrement floride.
On se prend pour un oiseau, on se prend pour un super héros. On peut dans ces moments délirants commettre des actes extrêmement dangereux pour soi, croire qu'on peut sauter d'un toit et qu'on va s'en sortir.
On peut avoir des troubles du comportement par rapport à ses proches. On peut frapper quelqu'un parce qu'on trouve qu'il a tout d'un coup un regard comme un diable qui vous veut du mal.
On se sent observé, on a l'impression qu'il y a des micros cachés dans les pièces. On a vraiment ce qu'on appelle ces symptômes délirants.
On hallucine très souvent. On hallucine et souvent des voix. Des voix qui sont rarement gentilles, qui sont plutôt des voix menaçantes, qui vous obligent à faire des choses, qui vous poussent à commettre des actes.
On parlait tout à l'heure de la mauvaise compréhension du grand public de la schizophrénie, mais sur base des symptômes que vous présentez maintenant, on est en plein dans le cliché du fou sur le toit de l'asile en fait.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. Je dirais que la schizophrénie, clairement, porte en elle ce que depuis toujours, on associe à l'image du fou, à l'image de la folie, de la personne bizarre, de la personne qui parle toute seule dans la rue.
Néanmoins, j'insiste et je pense qu'on aura l'occasion certainement d'en reparler. J'insiste qu'on est très rarement, beaucoup plus rarement que le public le croit, dans la dangerosité.
On n'est pas dans la perversion sexuelle, on n'est pas dans ces gens qui vont attaquer des petites filles. Parce que j'insiste déjà dès à présent, parce que l'évolution de la société a fait qu'on a souvent colmaté.
Nous avons connu des affaires épouvantables en Belgique, vous le savez, qui ont,
vraiment eu comme conséquence d'associer, je dirais, la grande délinquance sexuelle, qui est une sorte de— mais qui n'est pas une folie au sens de la schizophrénie, la grande perversion sexuelle et la schizophrénie.
Ce qui fait que ces patients souffrent d'un rejet social souvent massif. Mais donc, si nous revenons à ces symptômes, en effet, c'est ce qu'on peut appeler les symptômes les plus fous, souvent incompréhensibles.
Ils ont des discours qui ne vous permettent pas de rentrer en contact avec eux. Donc pour revenir à votre question, la première chose qu'on a à gérer, c'est souvent ces symptômes qui,
s'ils ne sont pas pris en charge, sont parfois extrêmement perturbants pour la personne, pour l'entourage et souvent ne permettent pas de rentrer en contact et en relation avec les patients.
Quand vous dites pris en charge, on parle de camisole de force ? On parle de—
Non, alors ce sont des termes évidemment qu'on associe beaucoup à la psychiatrie. C'est des choses, bien sûr, qu'on ne fait absolument plus.
Ce qu'on a aujourd'hui, c'est un arsenal thérapeutique médicamenteux,
c'est vrai, qui sont souvent absolument indispensables dans cette phase-là pour faire en sorte que ces idées soient diminuées, qu'elles soient rassemblées, que le patient arrête de s'éparpiller comme on le voit souvent.
Donc ce sont des médicaments qui agissent en général pas forcément très vite. C'est ça la difficulté, c'est qu'ils mettent souvent un certain nombre de semaines à agir
et qui vont petit à petit permettre au patient de retrouver, je dirais, un état cognitif et un état de l'imagination beaucoup plus serein.
Très bien. Et alors, cette assistance sur base de médicaments, est-ce qu'elle se fait de manière temporaire ?
Est-ce qu'elle se fait à vie ? Est-ce qu'on guérit la schizophrénie ?
Ah, vous y allez fort d'emblée, donc c'est une— Non, écoutez, c'est une question... Donc pour finir, on a de nouveau, on n'a pas la certitude, comme psychiatre
parlant du fait que nous voyons a priori toujours les gens malades et les gens qu'on a vus au départ.
Si je regarde comment ils évoluent, c'est vrai que la guérison au sens d'une grippe, au sens d'une appendicite n'est pas fréquente.
Elle existe. Nous avons tous, comme psychiatres, des exemples où clairement quelqu'un s'en est tout à fait sorti.
Néanmoins, il reste souvent quelques caractéristiques, mais qu'on pourrait imaginer voir même comme des caractéristiques de personnalité.
Et donc on voit aujourd'hui des chemins de ce qu'on appelle de rémission. Le patient n'a plus ces symptômes, il n'a plus ces troubles du comportement.
Il peut retrouver une vie tout à fait satisfaisante, que ce soit une vie sociale, une vie affective. Il peut même travailler. Je dirais que là,
on retrouve énormément de déterminants environnementaux et sociaux qui vont permettre que ces patients puissent avoir accès au travail, puissent se sentir, je dirais,
pas trop rejetés dans leur logement, puissent avoir, je dirais, suffisamment de support social pour connaître une vie relationnelle satisfaisante.
Donc on a aujourd'hui beaucoup d'indications et c'est ce qui fait que la psychiatrie reste un métier assez compliqué, hein, puisqu'on va beaucoup parler du volet médical.
Mais on sait aujourd'hui que l'évolution d'un patient
schizophrène, si vous prenez un patient qui a la même maladie, si vous prenez le même patient, mais que vous le mettez en Belgique, en Hollande,
en Angleterre ou dans un pays, je dirais encore un peu plus lointain, ce même patient aura un destin tout à fait différent.
Et ça, c'est forcément, on le sait aujourd'hui, fortement déterminé par l'environnement social,
par une volonté, je dirais souvent politique ou d'organisation des soins qui va faire en sorte que des éléments aussi importants que le travail, les relations sociales
puissent soutenir l'évolution du patient.
On aura l'occasion de revenir sur ces différentes écoles de traitements médicaux. Mais donc, pour revenir sur ce que vous disiez, le cas majoritaire alors du patient qui n'atteint jamais alors vraiment la rémission totale,
est-ce qu'il doit consulter alors son médecin de manière régulière ?
Est-ce qu'il doit alors dépendre de médicaments à vie ?
Alors, la prise en charge de la schizophrénie est clairement une prise en charge au long terme. C'est toujours difficile de dire à vie, on n'en sait, pour finir, pas grand-chose.
En tout cas au long terme, ça, c'est sûr. La rémission, je précise, n'est pas rarissime. Elle n'est pas fréquente, mais elle est possible.
Pour une partie, je dirais, le chiffre qu'on cite souvent, c'est que pour un quart, en tout cas des patients, une rémission satisfaisante est accessible.
Mais pour cela, en effet, il y a besoin d'un suivi qui n'est pas qu'un suivi de médicaments, même si on sait que la couverture médicamenteuse, la prophylaxie, comme on dit, médicamenteuse est essentielle.
On voit malheureusement trop souvent des patients qui, après parfois un moment assez long où ils se sont sentis bien, décident tout seuls comme ça d'arrêter le traitement.
Et malheureusement, on voit souvent que dans les mois qui suivent, une rechute apparaît. Donc c'est en tout cas, en effet, un traitement médicamenteux au long cours avec des médicaments qui aujourd'hui,
ne donnent pas trop d'effets secondaires, sont bien mieux acceptés et tolérés que ceux qu'on connaissait avant.
Mais c'est bien plus que cela. C'est aussi tout un chemin, j'ai envie de dire, tant personnel. Et il y a une importance majeure de ce qui est
d'ordre du suivi psychologique pour des patients, même schizophrènes, même si souvent, ça demande des adaptations dans le type de suivi psychologique qu'on fait,
qui permettent en général au patient à quand même faire tout un cheminement par rapport au sens, hein, de tout, de tout ce qu'il traverse.
Et souvent, il y a aussi besoin d'un suivi psychosocial, comme on dit, qui permet, je dirais, de faciliter peut-être l'intégration psychosociale de ce patient.
On sait aujourd'hui, par exemple, que ce sont des patients qui bénéficient pas mal de tout ce qu'on peut faire dans l'aide de l'accès au logement, de l'accès au travail.
Il y a de nouveau des expériences très intéressantes qui montrent qu'à partir du moment où vous avez un logement satisfaisant et un travail satisfaisant, eh bien, il y a là un véritable...
C'est plus que simplement un traitement en plus, ça a des effets thérapeutiques en soi pour permettre au patient cette rémission.
Donc, si le patient interrompt son traitement, sa prise de médicaments, il est possible qu'à ce moment-là, très rapidement après, un épisode se présente, un épisode hallucinatoire.
J'essaie alors simplement de comprendre. Comment est-ce qu'on est en capacité de découvrir un patient qui aurait alors atteint la rémission si on conseille à tout le monde de ne surtout pas arrêter son traitement ?
Alors, je ne suis pas très comprendre. Quand on dit rémission—
Oui.
...la rémission, c'est un état qui parfois, et très souvent d'ailleurs, inclut le fait que vous continuiez à prendre vos médicaments.
D'accord, oui.
La rémission, ce n'est pas être— c'est là où, c'est là que peut-être dans le grand public, c'est ça qui est difficile à comprendre, c'est que quand on dit guérison en médecine, ben c'est souvent que voilà, vous ne prenez plus de médicaments—
Ouais.
...vous n'avez plus à aller voir le médecin, vous avez tout à fait recouvré votre état de santé antérieur. La rémission, c'est pas ça.
Vous gardez la maladie. Et en fait, le modèle de la psychiatrie, les maladies psychiatriques existent dans la médecine organique.
Si je parle, je sais pas moi, du diabète, de plein de maladies,
vous pouvez être en rémission d'un diabète, à savoir que votre sucre sanguin est tout à fait dans des normes satisfaisantes, mais néanmoins, vous devez continuer à prendre votre insuline tous les jours et de manière très régulière.
Eh bien, c'est un peu le même modèle—
D'accord, oui.
...pour une grande partie de nos pathologies, hein, certainement les maladies psychiatriques les plus lourdes. Quand on dit une rémission, c'est pas de symptômes, un état d'intégration psychosociale satisfaisant, une vie quasi normale.
Néanmoins, ceci est permis parce que, comme je vous l'ai dit, les médicaments sont toujours présents, le suivi psychologique est toujours présent, le suivi psychosocial est toujours présent. Donc
ça, c'est le schéma de la rémission. C'est plus qu'un schéma, c'est une réalité qui permet à une partie qui n'est pas si petite que cela, hein, même s'il y a toujours un discours un peu défaitiste dans le grand public, qui n'est pas si petite que ça,
qui permet à le patient de vivre une vie quasi normale.
D'accord, effectivement. Là, vous remettez un petit peu les pendules à l'heure et c'est effectivement beaucoup plus clair maintenant que vous avez fait la différence entre rémission et guérison.
À ce moment-là, comment est-ce que vous expliquez que la rémission, même sous traitement, enfin même systématiquement sous traitement médicamenteux, elle soit aussi rare ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait que alors qu'on a cette médecine, alors qu'on a ces médicaments, comme vous dites, plutôt efficaces, plutôt discrets, plutôt confortables, ce ne soit pas plus courant, une rémission ?
C'est là où, comme je vous disais tout à l'heure, la psychiatrie est un métier qui plonge ses racines et ses pratiques dans des disciplines extrêmement variées.
Donc, c'est là où je vais quitter un peu ma casquette de médecin et vous parler du fait que voilà, il n'y a rien à faire.
Nous avons affaire non pas à des patients, non pas à des schizophrènes. Nous avons affaire à chaque fois à des singularités, des patients tous différents, des chemins de vie, des personnalités.
Et il est clair, mais ça, j'imagine que vous pouvez même facilement comprendre ça pour vous, qu'une maladie qu'on a pendant toute sa vie, eh bien, n'est pas quelque chose qu'on accepte facilement. Il y a déjà,
par le fait même d'avoir cette fragilité
schizophrénique, donc qui fait partie du champ des psychoses, une atteinte
de la manière dont on comprend le monde, dont on appréhende le monde, dont on appréhende les relations aux autres, assez particulière et qui, clairement, vous met souvent dans un vécu, parce qu'on connaît bien, on a
beaucoup de patients schizophrènes, ont écrit, ont peint, ont fait des films, ont dit leur vécu.
On sait à quel point leur chemin de vie est toujours entaché par une impression qu'on ne les comprend pas, on ne les accepte pas, que le monde est pour finir
plus malade qu'eux. Et donc
cette difficulté d'accepter d'aller voir un médecin, de prendre un médicament tous les jours, d'aller voir une assistante sociale, que sais-je encore, reste pour beaucoup
un vrai, une vraie difficulté qui explique que régulièrement, en tout cas, ils essayent de reprendre une liberté individuelle par rapport à ça.
Et c'est pourquoi il est peut-être important, plus que ce qu'on a fait jusqu'aujourd'hui, de changer un peu notre manière de faire, de voir ces maladies, de les encadrer.
Ce côté un peu paternaliste de la médecine qui viendrait dire : « Fais ceci, fais cela, prends tel médicament parce que je sais, moi, comme médecin, ce qui est bon pour toi », dans ce type de pathologie ne donne pas très bien.
Et on a aujourd'hui plein d'indications et plein d'idées et plein de pratiques déjà qu'on fait parfois à droite, à gauche, que ce soit en Belgique ou ailleurs, qui montrent qu'on doit parfois un peu renverser la manière de faire.
Donc, pour résumer un petit peu l'essence du problème, si j'ai bien compris, en fait, la façon d'appréhender le monde de ces patients schizophrènes est un obstacle en soi à leur traitement médical.
On pourrait le dire comme ça, en effet. Cette posture, je dirais, de la relation médecin-malade est très efficace à partir du moment où vous êtes dans une maladie organique dont on connaît le— dont on peut circonscrire le champ.
On sait qu'il y a un début, ça a une fin, on sait de quoi il s'agit. Et je dirais où votre personnalité, pour finir, n'est pas tellement engagée, même si la relation entre un médecin et son patient est très importante.
Mais néanmoins, vous pouvez vous faire soigner, je dirais, en gardant toutes vos idées par rapport à toutes sortes de choses.
À partir du moment où vous soignez des patients qui souffrent de maladies mentales, leur être tout entier, leur façon de voir les choses, d'appréhender la vie fait partie intégrante de cette relation.
Et c'est sûr qu'un paternalisme ou quelque chose qui est de trop dirigiste ou qui viendrait trop sous-entendre que vous avez la vérité et que eux ne l'ont pas, pose vraiment un problème dans notre métier.
C'est intrinsèque à notre profession.
Mh. Oui. On reviendra alors très certainement sur cette notion de paternalisme dans les traitements médicaux.
On parlait il y a un instant de ces fameux épisodes hallucinatoires, donc le symptôme le plus évident. Quelles conséquences est-ce que ça peut avoir sur la vie du patient, sur son projet de vie, sur son environnement ?
Est-ce qu'on parle d'épisodes qui ont des conséquences légères, anecdotiques, amusantes ou bien est-ce que, au contraire, c'est beaucoup plus grave ?
Si on imagine, par exemple, un patient qui est sous traitement médicamenteux et qui décide d'interrompre ce traitement, quelle est la gravité de ce qu'on va pouvoir observer à ce moment-là ?
Alors, il y a plusieurs dimensions. De nouveau, d'abord, au niveau médical, on a aujourd'hui certaines indications, même si de nouveau, rien n'est tout à fait sûr, mais on a des indications que chaque épisode,
chaque nouvel épisode va altérer, hein, un peu plus, je dirais, les facultés cognitives du patient.
Donc ces patients, avec ces crises répétées, vont sans doute perdre des facultés cognitives, vont perdre, je dirais, des capacités fonctionnelles.
On pense même que les atteintes cérébrales dont on a certaines idées, hein, quand on étudie vraiment la matière, la matière du cerveau, ben là aussi, montrent des dégradations en fonction de l'évolution de ces crises.
Ça, c'est sur le plan médical. Hein, donc il y a déjà là une question de comment est-ce qu'on pourrait protéger ce cerveau de ces multiples crises.
La première attitude qu'on a aujourd'hui, c'est ben que ces crises n'arrivent pas.
Mais alors par contre, et je dirais que c'est aussi important, si pas plus important, ça fait souvent énormément de dégâts dans leur vie relationnelle, dans leur vie familiale, par rapport au stigma social.
Je dirais autant on voit encore beaucoup de monde, beaucoup de soutien dans les débuts de la maladie, lors des premières crises, autant très vite, ces patients sont souvent de plus en plus esseulés, de moins en moins compris.
Les familles se fatiguent, les familles se désespèrent et il n'y a pas à les juger. C'est un accompagnement extrêmement éprouvant, hein, ces maladies.
Ça veut dire aussi que si on avait un petit job, eh bien souvent, on accepte une crise, mais la deuxième, on le perd. Ça veut dire qu'on a parfois une habitation individuelle,
on est en autonomie, mais les voisins acceptent une crise, deux, mais la troisième, ça ne va plus.
Et je dirais qu'ils se liguent pour vous faire expulser. C'est des choses vraiment qu'on voit tous les jours.
Donc, la dégradation psychosociale de ces crises multiples est souvent extrêmement, extrêmement catastrophique.
Et donc ça, c'est pour une dégradation à un niveau plutôt social alors.
Le premier exemple que vous évoquiez, qui est donc une dégradation des capacités cognitives, si je comprends bien, on peut donc imaginer un patient, disons, quinquagénaire, qui serait à ce moment-là porteur de,
de ces séquelles, porteur de ce cerveau endommagé.
Il serait alors très handicapé par rapport à son autonomie et à ses capacités à appréhender la vie. Quelle assistance est-ce qu'on propose exactement à des patients comme celui-là ?
Je rappelle bien qu'on parle de la schizophrénie, mais si on était un peu plus précis dans la terminologie, on parlerait des schizophrénies, tellement il y a des variétés d'évolution.
Il y a donc un spectre.
Il y a un spectre. Donc c'est vraiment— c'est un ensemble qui, bon, dont on donne un nom, mais qui recouvre des réalités, tant dès le départ que dans l'évolution de celles-ci, très très différentes, pour nos patients.
Donc, ceux qui ont la malchance, je dirais, d'évoluer de manière très, ce qu'on appelle déficitaire, c'est-à-dire qu'avec les épisodes, ces déficits cognitifs, ces pertes de faculté sont à l'avant-plan.
En effet, parfois, autour de la cinquantaine, se retrouvent dans des difficultés d'autonomie, de vie très difficile. Alors là, on peut parler, je dirais, de l'histoire de la psychiatrie.
Ben l'histoire de la psychiatrie, et particulièrement en Belgique, la Belgique, sachez que la Belgique est un des pays qui a le taux de lits psychiatriques par tête d'habitant des plus élevés au monde.
Nous sommes troisième pays quasi dans le monde. Si vous prenez l'ensemble des habitants belges
et que vous comparez ça au nombre de lits psychiatriques, ça veut dire que la Belgique a toujours eu une organisation des soins psychiatriques très très hospitalière.
En Belgique, nous avons énormément de très très grands hôpitaux psychiatriques avec des centaines et des centaines de lits.
Et donc dans ces hôpitaux, pour répondre à votre question,
pendant tout un temps, on a trouvé en effet beaucoup de ces patients qui n'étaient pas forcément très âgés, mais qui s'étaient installés, dont c'était pour finir le seul et unique lieu de vie et qui y passaient des années et des années.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui au cœur d'une réforme de la santé mentale, hein, qui est très active, qui est déjà reprise par...
On sera le troisième gouvernement, on attend le troisième,
mais qui continue cette, hein, cette réforme qui a pour objectif, qui n'est pas le seul, mais un des objectifs majeurs, en effet, c'est de changer de paradigme, d'être moins hospitalocentrique, comme on dit, c'est-à-dire d'essayer des...
ce qu'on appelle la désinstitutionnalisation, essayer que pour ces patients-là,
le seul destin ne soit pas de rester pendant vingt ans, trente ans, quarante ans dans un hôpital psychiatrique, donc de beaucoup plus axer les soins du côté de la communauté.
Donc c'est un chemin très long qui va prendre très longtemps, mais néanmoins qui a déjà une réalité. On trouve beaucoup de ces anciens services chroniques, comme on appelait, hein, qui ont gelé leur vie.
Ils n'ont pas tout à fait fermé, mais on leur a permis de garder les moyens humains, les infirmiers, les soins, tout ça, mais de faire ces soins dans la communauté.
Se sont mis en place différentes équipes mobiles qui permettent parfois
de pouvoir proposer à ces patients de retourner vivre dans la communauté, dans des logements collectifs, dans des maisons de repos et de pouvoir avoir le soin qui vient à eux plutôt que de leur proposer de rester pendant des années et des années.
Parce qu'on sait, ça, de nouveau, c'est pas médical, mais on sait que quand vous avez passé une dizaine d'années à l'hôpital psychiatrique, globalement,
c'est très très très très difficile de retrouver une vie autonome parce qu'on ne sait quasi plus rien faire.
On ne sait plus faire son lit, on ne sait plus cuisiner, on ne sait plus faire ses courses. On est terriblement dépendant.
Et donc ça, c'est l'objet de la réforme qui est en cours. À ce stade, on en est où ? Qu'est-ce qu'il reste à faire ?
Il reste beaucoup de choses à faire. D'abord, les hôpitaux, comme je vous ai dit, ont diminué le nombre de lits, mais en ont encore beaucoup, hein.
Il y a clairement encore un taux d'hospitalisation, je dirais, en Belgique, qui pose encore question.
D'autres pays font autrement. Mais néanmoins, ce qu'il faut, c'est habituer petit à petit
l'ensemble des soignants, de ceux qui s'occupent de ces patients, à être dans un réflexe moins hospitalier, d'hospitaliser peut-être moins vite, moins longtemps.
Il y a aussi toute la question de qu'est-ce qu'on fait à l'hôpital, hein. Donc, il faut ce qu'on appelle intensifier sans doute les soins hospitaliers.
Il faudrait que quand vous y rentriez,
eh bien les choses soient faites plus rapidement, que vous ayez accès à plus de soignants pour une période limitée et qui vous permette à ce moment-là de retrouver plus rapidement votre lieu de vie, sachant que tout ce que vous,
tout ce que vous accumulez souvent à l'hôpital
va, entre guillemets, mettre en danger vos capacités à revivre dans la communauté.
Vous disiez : il y a en Belgique beaucoup de lits d'hôpitaux par personne. Est-ce qu'il y a une raison historique derrière ça ?
Est-ce qu'on connaît l'explication de cette différence, de cette particularité ?
Ah tout à fait. Il y a... Je vous encourage et vos auditeurs d'aller voir un magnifique musée qui s'appelle le Musée du docteur Guislain, qui se trouve à Gand,
et qui d'ailleurs explique bien toute la genèse de la psychiatrie belge qui a débuté surtout en Flandre, puisque c'est un chanoine.
Donc c'est un peu après la Révolution française. Donc, vous voyez que ça remonte à longtemps.
C'est un peu l'union d'une charité à l'époque, d'une charité chrétienne, hein, donc de ce fait de se soucier des misérables, qui s'est associée
à une vision assez progressive de la médecine, le fameux docteur Guislain, qui était un médecin gantois.
Et cette association de la charité chrétienne et,
je dirais, d'une médecine qui se voulait plus humaniste, a donné lieu à la naissance d'un ordre hospitalier qui s'appelle les Frères de la Charité de Gand,
qui aujourd'hui est le premier ordre, je dirais, religieux actif dans le champ de la psychiatrie, qui travaille dans à peu près quatre-vingt pays, qui ont des dizaines et dizaines d'hôpitaux psychiatriques,
mais qui, c'est vrai, à l'époque, l'ont vu comme un lieu où on accueillait, hein, les patients.
On les traitait certainement mieux que ce qu'on faisait avant, puisqu'avant, globalement, les patients psychiatriques étaient traités exactement comme les prisonniers, comme les malfrats, comme les indigents.
On les retrouvait dans les prisons, on les retrouvait dans les lieux vraiment de perdition absolue.
C'était à l'époque extrêmement novateur de proposer qu'on écoute ces gens, qu'on leur parle, déjà, qu'ils étaient dignes, hein, d'attention.
Et puis sont nés toutes sortes de traitements qui aujourd'hui, évidemment, paraissent tout à fait désuets, voire incompréhensibles.
Néanmoins, c'est un mouvement qui est né à cette époque-là, beaucoup en Flandre, et qui a donné lieu à la création d'importantes structures d'accueil.
Ces grands hôpitaux qu'on appelait avant asiles, qu'on n'appelle plus asiles, qui ont eu certainement des vertus, hein. Moi, je crois qu'il faut pas faire l'histoire avec notre casquette d'aujourd'hui.
Qui ont eu des vertus incroyables de permettre à des gens vraiment d'être,
d'être considérés totalement différemment, mais qui, c'est vrai aujourd'hui,
apparaissent surtout dans leur gigantisme, dans leur un certain immobilisme et qui aujourd'hui, bien sûr, sont challengés par d'autres buts que nous avons par rapport à ces patients.
J'insiste aussi pour vous dire que, je pense l'avoir dit pour la schizophrénie, les patients psychiatriques dans des états délirants, on ne parvient pas à rentrer en contact avec eux.
Ce n'est que dans les années cinquante, mille neuf cent cinquante, que sont apparus les premiers médicaments qui ont pu calmer ces symptômes, mais...
Et qui ont permis qu'on rentre en contact avec ces patients. Avant cela, ces patients étaient bien sûr accueillis dans les hôpitaux, mais déliraient toute la journée, parfois pendant des années, et étaient dans leur monde tout à fait fermés.
C'est intéressant puisqu'on rentre un petit peu ici dans la question, voilà, de l'idéologie, hein. Vous disiez, voilà, avec cette charité chrétienne qui remonte
à quelques siècles et qui a encore des conséquences aujourd'hui.
Est-ce qu'il y a un débat d'idées quand on parle de psychiatrie ? Parce que, voilà, on aura bien compris que vous défendez aujourd'hui une position bien plus moderne, hein, comme quoi il faudrait,
une approche beaucoup moins centrée sur l'hospitalisation.
Est-ce qu'il y a un débat d'idées ou bien est-ce qu'au contraire tout le monde s'accorde à dire que Vincent Dubois a raison sur ce point ?
Il y a quand même une tendance générale et partagée pour reconnaître que par rapport à nos patients,
même s'il ne faut surtout pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain, comme on dit, et l'hôpital a encore toute sa raison d'être, tout son sens, c'est vraiment...
Mais tout le monde s'accorde à dire en effet que l'hôpital doit peut-être trouver une place,
une vraie place, je dirais, de partenaire d'une étape dans un parcours de soins qui doit être vu de manière beaucoup plus générale, beaucoup plus globale.
Ça, je pense que plus personne ne conteste cela. Bon néanmoins,
il est clair que c'est un débat qui reste extrêmement complexe parce que moi, comme psychiatre, quand je vous parle ici, ben oui, en effet, j'ai une certaine action possible à l'hôpital par rapport à nos patients dans le champ médical.
Mais par rapport à tout ce que je vous ai dit, vous vous rendez bien compte que beaucoup des éléments importants pour le devenir de nos patients ne dépendent pas des médecins.
Ils dépendront de la société, de l'organisation politique, de la manière dont on vit entre nous, dont le stigma social est plus ou moins partagé.
Enfin, vous vous rendez compte que c'est ça le problème de la psychiatrie. Les psychiatres, globalement, ont assez bien parlé, ont souvent pas mal d'idées, ont une vue sur certains phénomènes de société assez large.
Néanmoins, leur action reste une action, ben, déterminée par leur fonction, à savoir un métier de soignant, un métier d'accompagnant, un métier de médecin.
Mais nous ne sommes ni politiciens, ni...
je dirais, nous n'avons pas, bien sûr, toutes les cordes qui nous permettraient de dire : voilà, à partir de demain, hein, on va faire en sorte que nos patients soient mieux acceptés dans les lieux de logement,
aient accès au travail, puissent avoir toutes sortes d'aides qui aujourd'hui restent quand même plutôt dans l'ordre du champ social.
Donc c'est ça qui est assez compliqué. C'est qu'on sait aujourd'hui qu'on a besoin de tout le monde, beaucoup plus largement qu'avant, pour que nos patients aient une vie, une vie décente.
L'hôpital a toujours cette tendance de dire que puisqu'il n'y a pas ça, puisque la société reste, et ça, on peut le dire, reste très ambivalente par rapport aux maladies mentales.
Paradoxalement, on est beaucoup plus informé, beaucoup plus tolérant dans le champ de la santé mentale, et on y viendra certainement.
Autant la psychiatrie, les maladies psychiatriques qui ont toujours existé restent extrêmement, je dirais, visées et extrêmement peu comprises, peu acceptées dans la société.
Elles sont stigmatisées, oui.
Stigmatisées et je dirais, voire même, avec tout ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure, tout cet amalgame qu'on fait par rapport à la grande délinquance sexuelle notamment,
reste souvent, je dirais, très présent dans la société.
Il y a beaucoup de peur, il y a beaucoup d'incompréhension. Moi, je pense que c'est plus du côté d'un certain humanisme qu'on retrouve peut-être des différences, la manière,
du côté parfois d'un certain paternalisme, des choses comme ça, mais qui, je vous dis, déjà quand je vous en parle,
j'ai l'impression que je parle de choses qui ne sont plus actuelles.
Mais c'est sûr qu'à travers ce paternalisme, cet humanisme, on voit apparaître en effet des dimensions qui ont fait la différence entre la grande laïcité et, je dirais, des options plus religieuses.
Mais je vous dis, même ça, on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui, ce n'est plus le cas.
Quand on évoque la question du paternalisme, me reviennent immédiatement des souvenirs de mon dernier voyage aux États-Unis, notamment du côté de San Francisco, où les rues sont remplies de SDF qui consomment, voilà,
de l'héroïne à la vue de tous.
Et souvent, si on traîne dans les mauvais quartiers, ce qui était mon cas, on en trouvait qui parlaient tout seuls et qui avaient des comportements,
j'aurais tendance à dire psychotiques, même si je ne suis pas un expert.
Et ce qu'on m'a raconté, ce qu'on m'a expliqué, c'est qu'il y avait une histoire de la psychiatrie, une histoire des soins de santé mentale aux États-Unis, comme quoi...
Voilà, on m'avait expliqué qu'un journaliste était allé voir les forces de l'ordre en expliquant,
voilà, qu'il entendait des voix et on l'avait aussitôt enfermé dans un hôpital psychiatrique et que voilà, quand ce journaliste avait expliqué que non, en fait,
tout va bien, c'était juste un test, c'était juste une farce, laissez-moi sortir.
Mais on ne l'avait pas laissé sortir et qu'il y avait, voilà, une... C'est aussi très certainement lié au rapport dans la culture américaine, au rapport qu'ont les Américains avec leur gouvernement.
Sur base de toutes ces histoires, il y avait une sorte de grande méfiance de... Enfin voilà, qui sommes-nous pour enfermer un individu contre son gré ?
Donc on sent bien qu'il y a aussi un facteur culturel qui joue aussi très fort sur ces questions de paternalisme dans le soin médical.
C'est sûr que le soin forcé pose la question du paternalisme hein. Je dirais qu'il y a une histoire dans la psychiatrie par rapport aux soins forcés.
Aujourd'hui, en Belgique, on peut dire qu'on a une loi extrêmement bien équilibrée, une loi vraiment humaniste. Elle n'est pas si vieille, elle date de 1990.
Elle a remplacé une très vieille loi qui, en effet, posait de grands problèmes, je dirais, de ce paternalisme. C'était une loi qui permettait à un bourgmestre d'enfermer, je dirais, quelqu'un qui avait des symptômes, qui était perturbant.
Mais bon, on sait que cette loi a permis des enfermements tout à fait abusifs. C'est donc une loi, ce n'est pas qu'en Belgique, à peu près en 1990, dans l'ensemble des pays européens, on a réformé ces lois.
Et aujourd'hui, on a clairement une loi assez humaniste dans le sens où
un, on reconnaît que certains patients doivent être soignés parce qu'ils sont à certains moments, dans ces moments de crise notamment, tout à fait incapables de se prendre en charge.
Ils ont donc une maladie mentale, ils ne se sentent pas malades et donc ils refusent les soins et surtout parce qu'ils sont dangereux pour eux-mêmes et ou pour les autres.
Donc à partir du moment où on est dans ce cas de figure-là, on a une loi qui permet en effet de soigner ces patients pour une durée limitée, j'insiste hein, on parle de quarante jours.
Pas comme avant où on pouvait rester comme ça de manière indéfinie à l'hôpital. Pendant quarante jours, le patient a droit à un avocat, plus qu'à droit.
Souvent, on lui propose un avocat. Il y a l'intervention d'un tiers judiciaire qui régulièrement, hein, interroge nos pratiques.
Donc on est dans une loi beaucoup plus équilibrée. Mais déjà là, il y a en effet des différences assez, pour finir, philosophiques, idéologiques, puisque en Angleterre, par exemple, cette loi ressemble assez fortement à la nôtre.
Simplement, chez nous, quand on dit : on soigne les gens, on va jusqu'à leur imposer un traitement médicamenteux, parce qu'on sait bien que sans ce traitement médicamenteux, ils ne se stabiliseront pas.
Et bien en Angleterre,
on hospitalise ces patients de force, mais on ne va pas jusqu'à leur imposer un traitement. C'est déjà une différence très forte dans le sens où on dit : voilà, l'individu
est considéré comme tel, inviolable au sens vraiment strict du terme, inviolable au point de ne pas lui imposer un traitement.
Néanmoins, ça apparaît quand même à ce moment-là comme une loi qui protège surtout la société, mais qui protège pour finir assez peu le patient.
Puisque sans médicament, il restera sans doute beaucoup plus longtemps à l'hôpital, il se dégradera, on en a parlé tout à l'heure.
Par contre, la société est sans doute plus protégée parce que le patient n'est plus au sein de cette communauté.
Donc déjà au sein de ces lois, il y a des différences, mais il est clair que si vous voyez l'ensemble des pratiques psychiatriques, je dirais, d'il y a,
d'il y a, je sais pas, dix, trente, quarante ans, ces notions d'enfermement abusif ont bien sûr traversé les pratiques dans tous les pays.
Toujours sur cette notion de paternalisme... un patient à qui on imposerait un traitement médicamenteux, de manière générale, sur base de votre expérience,
est-ce qu'il va revenir vous voir en vous remerciant ou bien est-ce qu'au contraire, il aura une dent contre vous, il sera énervé, agacé par ce paternalisme, ce traitement forcé ?
Une fois qu'il aura atteint, voilà, le stade d'une certaine rémission.
Très intéressante question. Bon c'est sûr que, vous savez, quand on travaille comme médecin à l'hôpital, on est habitué aux pralines.
Je vous dis parce que quand on travaille en chirurgie, dans des services, à partir du moment où les patients sont contents, je dirais, il y a une petite tradition de remercier son médecin et tout ça.
Et je vous assure que comme jeune assistant, puisque j'ai dû faire des stages dans plein de services autres que la psychiatrie, j'ai pris sans doute à l'époque-
Des pralines au centre.
Il y en a. En psychiatrie, c'est très différent. En fait, c'est vrai que la majorité de nos patients ne vont pas vous en vouloir, mais ne vont pas forcément vous remercier au sens strict.
Dans le sens où, et bien ils vivent souvent des choses très difficiles à l'hôpital. Ils vivent des choses très, très difficiles au niveau émotionnel, au niveau personnel.
Et je dirais que voilà, on peut comprendre quand on s'en sort que ce n'est pas forcément ce qu'on préfère se souvenir de sa vie.
On est parfois un petit peu oublieux, je vais dire, de ce qui s'est passé. On reconnaît souvent que voilà, on a été bien pris en charge, que ça a été utile, mais c'est clairement pas l'épisode
qu'on garde le plus en avant dans sa vie.
Par rapport aux soins contraires, c'est encore plus compliqué. Ça, vous l'avez bien noté. C'est-à-dire qu'un petit pourcentage de gens, en effet, avec le temps, parce que tout ça, en général, prend du temps,
peuvent reconnaître qu'heureusement qu'on les a soignés à ce moment-là, parce que sinon, il y aurait eu des choses parfois extrêmement dommageables pour eux et ou pour les autres.
Mais c'est sûr que c'est un vrai cheminement. On voit ça parfois après deux, trois, quatre, cinq épisodes, hein, des patients qui disent : Ben voilà, j'ai appris à travers toutes ces difficultés.
J'ai appris à mieux me connaître, à mieux gérer mes symptômes, à mieux gérer ma maladie. Et à ces moments-là, souvent, on a une grande reconnaissance et souvent un lien très fort.
Vous savez, en psychiatrie, quand les choses se passent bien dans la relation avec nos patients, ça vous amène à parfois suivre des gens pendant des dizaines d'années.
Je veux dire, nous sommes nombreux. Moi, j'ai cinquante-trois ans là, mais j'ai déjà des patients que je suis depuis à peu près vingt ans.
Donc c'est des choses qui nous rapprochent, je dirais, de ce qu'on peut connaître en médecine générale ou dans toute cette médecine qui
n'est pas axée que sur la guérison, mais qui est plus, à voir, je dirais, les trajets de vie comme des accompagnements médicaux de différentes difficultés qui ont des moments plus difficiles, des moments meilleurs.
Et donc on a en même temps, hein, beaucoup de joie de voir ces patients qui vous suivent à travers leur évolution, qui sont souvent remerciants, mais qui clairement ne sont peut-être pas les patients...
Je dis souvent à des jeunes : si vous cherchez vraiment la reconnaissance immédiate de vos patients, ce n'est pas la psychiatrie que vous devez faire, ça, c'est sûr.
It's a thankless job.
Voilà.
Voilà, OK. Et à ce moment-là, est-ce que... Enfin, ce métier, de l'extérieur, évidemment, c'est difficile de juger, mais on a le sentiment que c'est un métier qui doit être pesant psychologiquement pour vous, le médecin.
On voit des choses qui ne sont pas forcément faciles à voir. Ne pas être remercié à la fin pour ce que ça vaut.
Alors oui, je pose une question qui est peut-être un petit peu intrusive, mais est-ce que vous vivez bien votre métier ?
Est-ce que c'est un métier qui vous rend heureux ?
Oui, c'est un métier formidable parce qu'en même temps, il vous amène au cœur, je dirais, des grandes questions de la vie, de la mort, de ce qui fait la sensibilité, les émotions.
C'est un métier très très ouvert sur les arts, sur la créativité, sur l'imagination. Donc on a accès d'emblée, je dirais, avec nos patients, à parfois des conversations, des sujets, tout ça, qui vraiment sont absolument passionnants.
Donc, je dirais que oui, c'est un métier dur émotionnellement, même si je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de métiers durs en médecine.
Il n'y a rien à faire, les médecins, a priori, à part les obstétriciens qui donnent la vie, qui assistent à la naissance, on est quand même toujours du côté de la maladie.
On vient vous voir parce que ça ne va pas, ceci, cela. C'est des plus petits ou des grands maux, mais néanmoins, il y a déjà d'office un rapport à la problématisation de la vie, je dirais, qui ancre toute la vocation médicale.
Mais je dirais qu'il y a certainement des métiers durs dans d'autres spécialités. Mais c'est sûr qu'en psychiatrie, c'est difficile émotionnellement parce que ça vient parfois vous
titiller dans des choses qui chez vous aussi sont parfois difficiles à accepter.
C'est pourquoi la formation personnelle des psychiatres reste quand même une des voies très importantes dans ce qu'on propose à nos étudiants et à ceux qui se destinent à cela.
Donc pendant très longtemps, même si ça diminue un peu aujourd'hui, beaucoup de candidats psychiatres faisaient un travail personnel eux-mêmes.
On a souvent recours à des supervisions, de trouver des lieux où on peut justement
avancer par rapport à ses propres émotions, sachant qu'il est clair que ce qu'on nous demande comme psychiatre, c'est d'être en même temps très sensible
à ce que les gens vivent, mais de ne pas inonder, bien sûr, le champ de la relation de ses propres problèmes.
Ça, c'est évidemment la base de, je dirais, de notre métier qui n'est pas toujours facile à faire et pour lequel il y a quand même beaucoup de moyens et d'encadrement possible pour accéder là.
C'est presque une bonne surprise puisque je pense, on le sentait un petit peu dans ma question, j'en présumais un métier usant psychologiquement ou très...
Voilà enfin. Un psychiatre qui rentre peut-être chez lui, qui prend des antidépresseurs ou je ne sais quoi. Mais finalement-
Non, tout à fait. Et ça arrive, mais ça, je pense que c'est vraiment... Je ne suis pas sûr et pas du tout même que nous soyons plus à risque que d'autres spécialités médicales.
Il y a, voilà, la question. On parle beaucoup aujourd'hui du burn-out des médecins. Elle n'est certainement pas majoritaire chez les psychiatres.
On le trouve beaucoup dans la médecine qui doit affronter d'énormes difficultés par rapport à leurs patients, par rapport à l'administration qu'on leur demande et surtout sans beaucoup de reconnaissance.
Donc la psychiatrie reste un métier, c'est vrai, traversé par une passion, je dirais, de l'humain dans ces multiples dimensions qui, je crois, nous permettent aussi de toujours voir la vie dans un ensemble très stimulant.
Alors, on va arriver tout doucement à la question plus large de la santé mentale, mais avant ça, on va juste conclure sur la question des maladies mentales.
On le disait, on a évoqué plusieurs fois les maladies mentales telles qu'elles sont
perçues par la société. On parle plutôt de personnes avec un entonnoir sur la tête, qui sont souvent la punchline d'une blague, des gens pour lesquels on n'a pas forcément
une grande empathie, mais qu'on a sans doute plutôt envie d'isoler, de cacher, d'oublier.
Ce sentiment-là, cette position par rapport aux maladies mentales, à la folie, pour employer ce terme, comment est-ce qu'on l'explique ?
D'où est-ce que ça vient ? Parce qu'on n'a pas forcément cette position face aux autres maladies.
Je crois que la folie, ça a toujours été quelque chose qui a interpellé
notre humanité, dans le sens où la maladie mentale, on peut la voir comme si vous preniez ça sur un continuum, comme un excès, un excès d'émotion, un excès de passion, un excès de sentiment, un excès de mouvement.
Et donc la folie est toujours quelque chose qui vient pointer des expériences de vie que tout le monde peut en même temps comprendre, mais dont on accepte très mal les excès.
Donc c'est quelque chose qui vous renvoie à votre humanité et en même temps qui vient pointer à quel point l'humanité, parfois peut être difficile, peut être angoissante, peut poser la question de la mort, de notre finitude.
Ce qu'a priori, une grande majorité de gens n'aiment pas. Ça vient questionner, ça vient vous bouleverser, ça vient vous titiller, ça vient dénoncer, ça vient crier des choses qu'on ne voudrait pas entendre.
Donc, le rapport à la folie a toujours été en même temps traversé par un mouvement de fascination. Et ça, si vous regardez le rapport à la folie, elle est partout dans la manière dont on...
dans les arts, dans la musique. Donc elle a en même temps une puissance d'attraction énorme et en même temps, elle fait très peur, elle dérange.
Et donc toute l'histoire du rapport à cette folie à travers les siècles est toujours, je dirais, ancrée dans cette ambivalence, dans ce double mouvement de fascination,
mais très vite aussi d'isolement, de rejet, d'exclusion, pour contenter, je dirais, ce qui nous rassure.
Très bien, mais je crois qu'à plusieurs reprises dans notre entretien, vous avez évoqué la question plus large de la santé mentale.
Un commentaire à faire à ce sujet, peut-être ?
La santé mentale, c'est parce que c'est un terme, vous voyez, les mots nous déterminent. Le langage est absolument important dans ces champs-là.
La santé mentale est une terminologie assez récente. Elle est très liée à une vision, je dirais, plus santé publique, de des troubles émotionnels, j'ai envie de dire, des troubles psychosociaux.
La santé mentale, c'est un concept très OMS, puisqu'il a été défini d'ailleurs, l'OMS, pas seulement comme une absence de maladie.
La santé mentale, ce n'est pas une absence de maladie, c'est un état de bien-être qui vous donne pleine satisfaction sur le plan relationnel, sur le plan social, sur le plan-
C'est très subjectif.
C'est extrêmement subjectif et c'est surtout très très large.
Donc on sait aujourd'hui en effet qu'une mauvaise santé mentale a beaucoup beaucoup d'influence sur votre capacité à travailler, à être en relation avec les autres, à être performant,
à être efficace au niveau économique, des choses comme ça.
Et donc ça remonte déjà à un certain nombre d'années. L'OMS a très vite pointé à quel point nos sociétés traversées par beaucoup de stress, par beaucoup
de changements sociétaux, étaient frappées par une augmentation importante des troubles psychosociaux, du stress psychosocial qui faisait craindre en effet un état de santé mentale s'appauvrissant,
dans nos civilisations, dans nos sociétés.
Et donc ça a ouvert bien sûr le champ de tout ce qu'on appelle
les troubles de santé mentale qui dépassent largement, bien sûr, j'imagine que quand je vous définissais les choses comme ça, vous comprenez aisément que ça dépasse largement le champ de la psychiatrie.
Ça le dépasse en termes de nombre, puisque aujourd'hui, on a des chiffres assez effrayants, hein. On dit qu'à peu près vingt pour cent de la population mondiale,
hein, présente à un moment donné de sa vie, hein, j'entends bien, à un moment donné de sa vie, ce qu'on appelle un trouble de santé mentale.
Donc, vous imaginez qu'en termes même de prévalence, on est dans quelque chose de très différent des troubles psychiatriques, hein, des anciennes, des maladies psychiatriques qui ont toujours existé.
Et surtout, ça nécessite une approche bien plus large que la médecine. Le danger de définir la santé mentale comme une maladie vient pour finir à médicaliser, hein, c'est ça le grand enjeu de notre société.
Et c'est quelque chose-
À médicaliser.
Je voulais juste que l'on insiste.
Tout à fait. Tout à fait. C'est-à-dire que les troubles de santé mentale aujourd'hui
sont, si on ne fait pas attention, sont souvent bien sûr attirés dans une espèce de simplification d'ordre médical et pour lequel ben voilà, le médecin, il est pour finir pas tout à fait armé pour l'affronter.
Il a bien sûr des traitements médicamenteux, il a l'écoute, il a l'accompagnement. Néanmoins, son action reste limitée. Et certainement,
comme il a les médicaments, on a beaucoup d'exemples comme ça où on dit aujourd'hui qu'on donne des médicaments trop rapidement.
On donne des médicaments trop rapidement dans les problèmes de stress, on donne des médicaments trop rapidement quand on est en deuil, on donne des médicaments trop rapidement, hein, quand on a des choses qui touchent plus
à de la dépressivité qu'à une réelle dépression.
Enfin voilà, c'est toutes des choses qu'on entend,
hein, et qui posent en effet des questions de comment aborder une société qui clairement montre des signes de stress psychosocial assez important et qui va plutôt croissant.
Très bien. Vincent Dubois, ça fait une heure que nous nous entretenons. J'ai posé toutes mes questions. Je pense que nous pouvons à présent nous quitter puisque vous avez, dans quelques instants, un rendez-vous.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir fait preuve d'une telle pédagogie.
Et merci beaucoup aussi parce que vos questions étaient très stimulantes.
Eh bien dans ce cas, tout le monde est satisfait. À très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Et c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode avec Vincent Dubois. Un grand merci à lui pour le temps qu'il m'a accordé. Et encore une fois, je suis sincèrement désolé pour les problèmes de son que vous avez pu constater.
Dans les semaines qui viennent, il y aura des invités comme Nathalie Maleux, la présentatrice du JT de la RTBF, et Olivia Gazalé pour déconstruire ensemble le mythe de la virilité.
Et dans quelques semaines, un épisode un petit peu spécial puisque ce sera en anglais et qu'on parlera de surveillance de masse.
Et non, mon invité n'est pas Edward Snowden, même si j'aurais beaucoup aimé. À très bientôt !